The browser does a lot
of heavy-lifting for us.
But as so often in
life, we don't always
know what we want
right from the start.
Imagine a website that
wants to show an image
of the current weather.
We don't know what
the weather is
going to be when the user visits
the website in the future.
Of course, we could have
loaded all the images
you might possibly need
from the very start,
but that becomes
impractical really quickly.
So let's talk about Ajax.
Ajax is a group of
web technologies
that let you make
requests programmatically
with JavaScript instead of
navigating and effectively
reloading the entire website.
XMLHttpRequest,
or XHR for short,
is the most common way
of doing it right now.
The API of XHR is arguably
confusing and outdated
compared to what
JavaScript offers nowadays.
That is why we are going
to skip talking about XHR
and use its successor
instead, Fetch.
Fetch does the exact same
thing but with a cleaner
API utilizing promises,
and therefore, it
integrates much better with the
rest of the modern JavaScript
APIs.
If you want to know
more about promises,
take a look at our course,
JavaScript Promises,
linked in the instructor notes.
With Fetch, you can utilize
all the HTTP methods
the protocol specifies and have
full control of which headers
are being sent--
well, almost all the headers.
Richard is going to
show you a small tool
to explore the Fetch API with.
Open up the networking
tab in your DevTools
to see if the browser actually
sent the request as you
specified it.